[Musique]
o o
e
beaucoup de bons souvenirs pour nous
tous radioactifs pierre bouteiller
souvenirs chez robert laffont
s'il est une des muses qui vous a
inspiré toute votre vie c'est bien celle
de la musique commence effet cette
rencontre dès l'enfance entre je dirais
mozart et bill evans ou fat voleurs ou
artérite mettant la radio par la radio
comme je le raconte dans le livre avec
mes parents on écoutait beaucoup la
radio jeudi ont regardé la radio
puisqu'un se réunissaient autour du
poste il veut pas de télévision et comme
les disques étaient chers qu'on n'avait
pas les moyens les acheter je dis nous
c'est à dire mon frère et moi mon frère
jacques est un très bon pianiste lui et
j'ai découvert la musique par la radio
en écoutant la bbc à la fois les grands
orchestres britanniques est également le
jazz que j'ai découvert par la radio et
après j'ai acheté le disque
et puis j'ai essayé de reproduire plus
ou moins bien ce que j'entendais les
bains j'ai je me suis mis au piano jazz
voilà vous entré à la radio donc très
très jeune et vous entrez en europe
numéro un c'est son nom à l'époque de
même que radio luxembourg
s'appelle en commun si ce n'est pas
encore rtl qu'est ce qui marque et la
spécificité là encore la différence
d'europe numéro 1 par rapport à la
concurrence
la modernité sur tous les plans c'est à
dire la mobilité de la prise de son avec
le nagra une magnétophone sublime
automatique très légers la mobilité des
coûte le transistor le vinyle qui
succède au se sent vite et on pouvait ou
si on meurt on achetait la neuvième
symphonie fallait ça faisait dix kilos
donc tout ça tout cet argent qu'ils y
ont donné de l'antenne et le ton d'encre
et qui a été induit avec un temps
d'antenne absolument nouveau et moderne
grâce à louis merlin qui est allé
prendre des recettes de radio aux états
unis tout le monde connaît votre
carrière qui se poursuit à la radio et
la télévision notamment à la radio et à
vous sont accolés le sens de la culture
des références l'indépendance d'esprit
et l'impertinence
c'est douloureux tout cela vivre où
c'est au contraire une jubilation de
tous les jours
ouais j'espère que j'ai pas trop raser
les auditeurs mais en tout cas je me
suis beaucoup desservi parce que entre
un bon mot une impertinence à dire à une
sincérité exprimés et un souci de
ménager de faire de la langue de bois
est ménagé ma carrière j'ai toujours
choisi
j'ai mal choisi puisque j'ai toujours
été virés de partout
[Musique]